[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen und guten
Abend viel Fußball hat heute Sven FOS im
Sport auch von mir einen schönen guten
Abend blicken wir auf die großen Themen
dieser
Sendung raus aus der Kampfzone erstmals
seit Kriegsbeginn dürfen einige hundert
Ausländer und verletzte den abgeregelten
gaserstreifen
verlassen schneller in Lohn und Brot das
Kabinett erleichtert geflüchteten den
Zugang in den Arbeitsmarkt und wir
gleichzeitig die Strafen für Schleuser
verschärfen und zwei frustrierte
Verlierer im DFB Pokal geht
Titelverteidiger Leipzig ziemlich
überraschend ko und Köln rutscht mit
seinem aus noch tiefer in die
Krise seit mehr als d Wochen herrscht
Krieg jetzt wurde der der Grenzübergang
Raffa von Gaza nach Ägypten das erste
mal für einige Menschen geöffnet so
wurden heute mindestens
335 Frauen Männer und Kinder mit
ausländischen Pässen darunter auch
deutsche sowie mindestens 76 verwundete
aus Gasa herausgebracht auf die Öffnung
sollen sich Ägypten Israel und die Hamas
geeinigt haben unter der Vermittlung
qatars Rafa ist eine geteilte Stadt ein
Teil liegt in Ägypten der andere im
Gazastreifen in Rafa ist der einzige
nicht von Israel kontrollierte Übergang
zum
Gazastreifen wie lange nun verletzte
Ausländer und Palästinenser mit
doppelter Staatsbürgerschaft hier Gaza
verlassen können ist nicht bekannt
golini
atai Rafa am Morgen zum ersten Mal
öffnet sich die Grenze für Menschen mit
ausländischen Pässen etwas mehr als 300
sollen heute Gaza verlassen haben
darunter sind heute nur einige wenige
deutsche sie sind Mitarbeiterin
h doch insgesamt mehr als 300 deutsche
wen immer noch auf die
Ausreise
SEF dass ich reomme aber leider B jetzt
wir sind n auf Straße wir haben keine
inf rfchaft an keine antwortet und wir
wollen od bleibt die Grenze am morgigen
Tag geöffnet oder nicht aufgrund der
internetausfälle sind viele kaum
erreichbar Familien erzählen von
getöteten Verwandten von Leichen
untertrümmern von Chaos und
Leid wir haben nichts zu essen nichts zu
trinken keine Hilfen nichts wir bitten
die Welt auf uns zu schauen es gibt
Menschen hier die nur Gras Blätter oder
trockenes Brot
essen Serv mehr als 80 verletzte die in
den überfüllten Krankenhäusern in gazer
nicht operiert werden können standen
heute auch auf der
ausreiseliste unser Haus wurde
beschossen ich wurde verletzt bekam
Splitter ins Auge und kann mit dem
rechten Auge nicht mehr sehen in Ägypten
soll ich operiert
werden 40 Krankenwagen fahren
schließlich von Ägypten aus nach gazer
hinein den ausreisedeal heute hat das
Golfemirat Qatar möglich gemacht in
Koordination mit Ägypten Israel den USA
und der Hamas schalten wir zu unserem
nahostkorspondenten Michael bewerunge
Michael welche Bedeutung hat diese
Grenzöffnung also sowohl aus ägyptischer
als auch israelischer Perspektive ist
dieser Deal nur begrenzt ausbaubar
Ägypten hat eine einige medizinische
Notfälle einige Mitarbeiter von
Hilfsorganisation ansonsten eine
Großzahl von Menschen mit doppelter
Staatsbürgerschaft ins Land gelassen die
aber vor allem einen palästinensischen
Familienhintergrund haben weitere
palästinensische Flüchtlinge will
Ägypten auf gar keinen Fall ins Land
lassen schon gar nicht in großer Zahl
und Israel hat eigentlich nur Interesse
daran dass keine Hamas
Menschen die einen Bezug zur Hamas haben
in aus das Land verlassen können und hat
diese Namensliste genau kontrolliert hat
wohl eine kontrollierte Liste auch nach
Ägypten geschickt und ansonsten fragen
sich die Israelis eher warum durfen
Menschen mit palästinensischem
Hintergrund und doppelter
Staatsbürgerschaft ausreisen aber die
israelischen Geiseln mit oder ohne
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft nicht vielen
dank Michael
bwerunger in der ZDF Sendung was nun
Frau berbock äußerte sich auch die
deutsche Außenministerin zu den
aktuellen Entwicklungen in nost sie
sagte eine Rolle Deutschlands sei es
Gesprächs Kanäle offen zu halten die
Diplomatie mache Fortschritte während
wir hier gerade sprechen haben mich die
Nachrichten erreicht dass deutsche auch
unter den Staatsangehörigen die jetzt
rauskommen mit dabei sind und wir sind
im Dauerkontakt mit den
Familienangehörigen und im Dauerkontakt
mit denjenigen die gerade rund um die
Uhr alles versuchen um auch die
deutschen Geiseln rauszubekommen aber zu
weiteren Details kann ich an dieser
Stelle nicht sagen und gleich nach
unserer Sendung in was nun Frau berb
können Sie das ganze Interview sehen und
das gibt es auch in unserem Online
Angebot jederzeit in unserer ZDF heute
App Israel ist auch heute wieder mit
Raketen aus Gaza beschossen worden
gleichzeitig rücken die israelischen
Truppen in Gaza nach eigenen Angaben
weiter vor der EU Außenbeauftragte
Borell äußerte sich entsetzt über die
hohe Opferzahl beim Beschuss des
flüchtlingsviertels jaabalia durch das
israelische Militär Tim Kröger
berichtet das Ausmaß der Zerstörung
macht klar wie heftig die Einschläge
gewesen sein müssen nach Angaben der
Hamas sollen auch sieben Geiseln die
während des Massakers am 7 Oktober nach
Gaza verschleppt wurden unter den Toten
sein auch am Tag nach den schweren
israelischen Luftangriffen auf das
flüchtlingsviertel jabalia suchen Sie
noch immer nach
Vermissten ich habe meine ganze Familie
verloren sie waren unschuldig einfach
hier was haben Sie getan alle sind
tot die israelischen Streitkräfte
hingegen betonten heute erneut man habe
in jabalia unter anderem den hohen
hamasführer Ibrahim biari getötet sowie
kommandostände und Tunnelsysteme
zerstört das zeigt einmal mehr wie die
mörderischen Terroristen Zivilisten als
Schutzschilde
benutzen auch heute veröffentlichte das
israelische Militär Bilder von Soldaten
die im Gazastreifen operieren und
offenbar weiter in das Gebiet
vorstoßen wir sind mitten im Krieg es
gibt starke Kämpfe in bewohnten Gebieten
in Gaza
stad hamasführer Ismail han drohte den
israelischen
Truppen sie werden im Sand von Gaza
untergehen sie müssen dafür einen hohen
Preis zahlen an allen Fronten das
schließt das Leben der Geisel mit
ein israelische Kriegsschiffe ins Rote
Meer geschickt worden offenbar eine
Reaktion auf den Abschuss von Raketen
und Drohnen aus dem Jemen durch die mit
dem Iran Verbündeten
hutibellen der Kanzler war auf Afrika
Reise die Innenministerin in Marokko die
Regierung sucht nach neuen Wegen in der
Asylpolitik sie hat ihren Ton und Kurs
geändert nach den schlechten Wahl und
Umfrageergebnissen und wegen der
steigenden Zahl an geflüchteten heute
hat das Bundes Kabinett einen Teil
seines migrationspakets beschlossen
unter anderem sollen geflüchtete früher
arbeiten dürfen Christian
Volk ein Anfang in Deutschland der Job
als Industriemechaniker eine Möglichkeit
für geflüchtete auf dem Arbeitsmarkt Fuß
zu fassen dieser Prozess soll künftig
schneller gehen so der Beschluss der
Bundesregierung es geht ja vor allen
Dingen um die Menschen die bereits hier
sind äh die wir aus integrationsgründen
ähm glauben frühzeitig in Arbeit zu
bringen ist hilfreich weil man sich dann
ein selbstbestimmtes Leben ermöglichen
kann in Deutschland und es führt
natürlich auch zur Akzeptanz in der
restlichen Bevölkerung wenn Menschen die
hierherkmen auch arbeiten die
wichtigsten Änderungen Asylbewerber
sollen früher arbeiten dürfen spätestens
nach 6 Monaten und geduldete sollen im
Regelfall eine Arbeitserlaubnis bekommen
bisher entschieden die Behörden von Fall
zu Fall zu wenig für
Menschenrechtsorganisationen die
Verhandlungen vorbei an die Realitäten
in denen geflüchtete Menschen in
Deutschland leben wir von proasul
fordern die vollständige Aufhebung von
Arbeitsverbote eine andere Stoßrichtung
hat die Kritik der CDU die Änderungen
würden mehr geflüchtete anziehen das
Problem des Fachkräftemangels aber nicht
lösen es wird halt weiter die tränung
zwischen Asyl und Arbeitsmigration
aufgehoben und damit ein weiterer
pullfaktor geschaffen ein weiterer
Anreiz
nach Deutschland zu kommen insbesondere
für diejenigen die eben kein
Schutzanspruch haben kein Bleiberecht
haben außerdem beschlossen härtere
Strafen für Schleuser ihnen droht
künftig in den meisten Fällen eine
Freiheitsstrafe von mindestens einem
Jahr die Migrationspolitik ein
Dauerthema am kommenden Montag beraten
Bund und Länder bei einem Spitzentreffen
über weitere
Maßnahmen das Kabinett hat außerdem noch
zwei Maßnahmen beschlossen um die
Verbraucherin und Verbraucher bei den
Energiepreisen zu entlasten zum einen
soll die
energiepreisbremse also die gedeckelten
Preise für Erdgas Strom und Wärme bis
Ende April verlängert werden zum anderen
brachte das Kabinett eine gesetzliche
Änderung auf den Weg um mit einem
milliardenzuschuss zu Netzentgelten die
Strompreise zu
dämpfen zum Krieg in der Ukraine es
seinen die heftigsten Angriffe seit
Beginn des Jahres gewesen heißt es heute
aus Kiev
das russische Militär hat innerhalb von
24 Stunden mehr als 100 Orte in der
Ukraine beschossen so der ukrainische
Innenminister nach Angaben von Behörden
wurden dabei mindestens vier Menschen
getötet und 14 weitere
verletzt in Tansania hat sich
Bundespräsident Steinmeier den
Gräueltaten der deutschen Kolonialmacht
ab 1905 gestellt er bat die Nachfahren
der Opfer um Vergebung er sei beschämt
über die Taten der deutschen sie führten
Zwangsarbeit ein erhoben hohe Steuern es
kam zum sogenannten magjimi Aufstand die
deutschen schlugen ihn brutal nieder
zerstörten Dörfer und Felder eine
Politik der verbrannten Erde eine
Hungerkatastrophe folgte insgesamt
starben rund 300.000 Menschen in
Tansania Steinmeier will sich dafür
einsetzen dass deutsche Museen die
geraubten Gebeine von Toten
zurückgeben der Amazonas in Südamerika
ist der mit Abstand wasserreichste Fluss
der Erde aber zur Zeit herrscht in
weiten Teilen seines Gebiets die
schlimmste döre seit Beginn der
Aufzeichnungen noch nie war der
Unterschied zwischen Regen und
Trockenzeit so dramatisch die
Niederschläge in den vergangenen Monaten
lagen weit unter dem Durchschnitt mit
schwerwiegenden Folgen christoph
röckerad hat sich in Brasilien selbst
ein Bild
gemacht hilflos gestrandet für Wochen
dort wo eigentlich der mächtige
fließen sollte Kapitän Junior Cesar
wurde vom Rückzug des Wassers
überrascht es ist so schnell gesunken 30
cm am Tag wir haben gegen die Zeit
gekämpft am Amazonas schleppen sie jetzt
Kanister zwischen den Rinnsalen die von
den Flüssen übrig geblieben sind
Trinkwasser per Boot wir begleiten
Narciso und Domingos selbst mit den
kleinen flachen boten wird es immer
schwieriger voranzukommen wir bleiben
immer wieder stecken alle müssen mit
anpacken damit wir
weiterkommen der Fluss ist hier unsere
Straße hier in unserer Region ist der
Fluss alles ohne den Fluss sind wir
nichts heute haben sie es noch einmal
zum Haus geschafft doch je mehr das
Wasser zurückgeht desto beschwerlicher
wird es diese Treppe hier führt
normalerweise das ganze Jahr über ins
Wasser während der Regenzeit steht das
Wasser hier und während der Trockenzeit
ist es ungefähr hier am en Ende der
Treppe jetzt aber ist das Wasser viel
tiefer weit weg und das hat es hier noch
nie gegeben mit Folgen für die ganze
Welt waren ein Wissenschaftler der
Amazonas Regenwald regelt die
Luftfeuchtigkeit in der Atmosphäre weit
über Südamerika hinaus wir sprechen von
fliegenden Flüssen also Wassermassen die
über dem Wald verdunsten nach Norden und
Süden ziehen und so das Weltklima im
Gleichgewicht halten anderenfalls ändert
sich das
Weltklima sie auf das Wasser warten
wächst die Sorge dass etwas
grundsätzlich aus den Fugen geraten ist
am Amazonas und mehr über den Regenwald
ohne Regen und die Angst um den Amazonas
können Sie im auslandsjournal sehen um
22:15 Uhr am Halloweenabend haben
Randalierer in mehreren deutschen
Städten für polizeieinsetze gesorgt die
Einsatzkräfte wurden auch mit Böllern
beworfen im Hamburger Stadtteil habur
setzte die Polizei in der Nacht
Wasserwerfer gegen eine Gruppe von rund
200 Jugendlichen ein sie hatten
Polizeikräfte massiv mit
Feuerwerkskörpern angegriffen die
Randalierer beschädigten Müllcontainer
und ein Supermarkt mehrere Personen
wurden
festgenommen weltweit haben vor allem
Katholiken am heutigen 1 November aller
Heiligen begangen es ist ein Gedenktag
für die Heiligen und Verstorbenen wie
hier in badenwürtenberg besuchten VI
Menschen die Gräber ihrer Angehörigen
und zündeten Kerzen an mit Gebeten Ehren
sie die Toten und bitten um deren
Erlösung gesetzlicher Feiertag ist aller
Heiligen auch in Bayern
Nordrhein-Westfalen rheinlandinfalz und
im
Saarland er war der Magier und
Illusionist der DDR Peter Kersten sogar
in Hollywood wurde er ausgezeichnet
jetzt ist zauberpeter im Alter von 80
Jahren in der Nähe von Dresden
gestorben nach der Wende bezauberte
Peter Kersten als Magic dog auch das
gesamtdeutsche Fernsehpublikum hierbei
musik liegt in der Luft im
ZDF die verschwundene Dame eine seiner
Spezialitäten und jetzt zum sportsvenn
die gute Nacht ist ja die deutschen
Fußballfrauen haben gewonnen ja und sie
waren damit die Chance auf die
Olympiaqualifikation dennoch war der 2:0
Erfolg in Island eher schmucklos oder um
es mit den Worten von Interims
Bundestrainer Horst rubesch zu sagen wir
müssen einfach besser
spielen jede Menge Redebedarf bei
Trainer rubesch und den Spielerinnen
nach dem Spiel Pflicht erfüllt aber
nicht geklänzt gegen Island dauert es 65
Minuten dann quin sicher vom Punkt mal
wieder es war heute ein ziemlicher
Krampf für uns wir hatten zwar sehr
viele Durchbrüche über außen aber haben
eben nicht geschafft diese Effektivität
reinzubringen das 2:0 dann ein Geschenk
in der Nachspielzeit jetzt gegen die
Gruppenersten aus Dänemark wir haben es
jetzt den beiden also vor allem jetzt im
W Spiel nicht schlecht gemacht und ich
glaube daran sollten wir einfach
anknüpfen jetzt geht erstmal zurück in
die Vereine stehen natürlich auch einige
Spiele an aber dann GT ja voller Fokus
auf zpiel ich denke ja zu Hause können
wir da schon Feuerwerk abfackeln
interimst trinerubch noch ohne
Punktverlust fürs Olympiaticket muss das
so
bleiben und gestern Abend DFB Pokal wer
schafft ins Achtelfinale für titelte RB
Leipzig endete eine lange Pokalserie von
13 Siegen am Stück im Bundesliga duuell
mit dem VfL Wolfsburg erzielte watslav
Cerny bereits in der 14 minute den
Siegtreffer für die Wölfe Marco Rose und
sein Team dagegen scheitern überraschend
in der zweiten Runde ins Achtelfinale
geschafft dagegen hat es Regionalligist
FC Homburg das größte Spektakel fand
aber auf dem Betzenberg statt Kaisers
lauttern sechster der zweiten Liga warf
den krieselnden erst fC Köln aus dem
Wettbewerb besser nicht hingucken heißt
es für Coach Steffen Baumgart nach einer
guten Stunde da kassieren seine Kölner
das dritte Gegentor und das Pokalaus ist
ganz nah du liegst einal 30 hinten und
der Gegner hat gefühlt dreimal aufs Tor
geschossen dann ist das schon die
Situation die wir Moment haben Glück
haben die Lauterer beim 1:0 teis Schuss
abgefälscht erstliga reif der Jubel auf
dem Betzenberg beim zweiten Lauterer
Treffer lassen die Kölner dem Schützen
Redondo zu viel Raum zwei Platzverweise
Schwächen Köln mehr als das 2:3 durch ut
ist nicht drin Lautern und Trainer
Schuster euphorisch Baumgart aber spürt
die Flasche sie ist jetzt beinahe leer
tja in der Zeitlupe tun die Gegentore
besonders weh autsch danke Sven und
diese Lottozahlen wurden gezogen die
Gewinnzahlen lauten 8 20 26 33 43 49
Superzahl ist die fün weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zf.de und im zdfext auf Seite
557 in diesen Stunden erreicht ein
Orkantief Mitteleuropa wie sich das in
Deutschland bemerkbar macht erfahren Sie
gleich von Katja hornifer um
21:45 Uhr läuft das heute journal mit
Christian siebas
[Musik]
tschüss
guten Abend in diesen Stunden erreicht
ein Orkantief die Westküsten von Irland
Großbritannien und Frankreich dieses
Orkantief es heißt kiren Deutsch Emir
wird bis morgen Abend über
Großbritannien weiter bis zur Nordsee
ziehen es bringt Orkanböhen mit bis zu
200 km pro Stunde mit und 10 m hohe
das bedeutet Bäume werden umstürzen und
die Infrastruktur wird in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen uns streift
dieses Orkantief nur am Rande heute
Nacht gibt's einige Regenschauer in der
Westhälfte sonst ist es trocken die
Temperaturen sinken auf 10 bis 2° und
morgen bleibt es mild da liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen bei 9° am Alpenrand
und 16° in der Lausitz und schon am
Vormittag beginnt es im Westen kräftig
zu regnen es wird ein starker bis
stürmischer Wind und in den
Mittelgebirgen gibt auch Sturmbö im
Osten ist es dagegen trocken am
Nachmittag beschränken sich die
kräftigeren regenfäer auf die Südhälfte
einige Schauer gibt's noch an der
Nordsee und in den nächsten Tagen geht
es wechselhaft weiter windig und es
droht am Samstag und am Sonntag im
Westen und Südwesten auch wieder Sturm
guten Abend